recently I was looking around my
bookshelves and I found the very first
chemistry book that I had at school
it wasn't new I got it after some other
pupil and it says copy the table on page
128 I don't know who wrote that and it's
full of really nice chemistry and all
sorts of inorganic chemistry reactions
but the one thing that really struck me
about this book is that it doesn't have
a periodic table and I find that
extraordinary Mendeleev invented the
periodic table in 1869 that's nearly a
hundred years before this book was
published it was published in 1961
especially to teach in organic chemistry
but I was quite lucky I also have my own
periodic table and here I also found my
very first periodic table here it is you
can see that the elements go up to
number 101
so even when I was a schoolboy it had
got to quite far in the periodic table
and I actually had two versions of this
I had this one here which was black
which I had next in my bed and a much
bigger one sort of full size like in the
classroom which was blue which I had on
the opposite wall of my room I had two
periodic tables in my bedroom and we
know that quite a lot of viewers have
periodic tables in their bedroom or even
on their shower curtains so we'd really
like to see some pictures of yours
so you can see how it compares with mine
but what is quite interesting if you're
into the periodic table is that the
groups used to be named 1a 2a up to 8
and 8 was a big group across here and
then they went 1 B 2 B 3 B and so on
7b and the rare gases were not or noble
gases didn't have a number and helium
sort of in this particular one floated
over here
not attached to anything else except
hydrogen this numbering system was
dreadful for schoolchildren because
teachers had this way of saying well
let's get the guys to write an essay and
we'll ask them to compare the chemistry
of manganese here in group 7a with the
chemistry of chlorine which is in group
7 B manganese is a metal I hope you know
if you look at our videos and chlorine
is a gas and there really isn't very
much in common at all so I think a lot
of people were put off chemistry by such
silly questions
nowadays the groups are numbered from 1
to 18 and teachers really don't now ask
questions compare groups 7 and 17
because it sounds silly and it was silly
then what do you think seeing your first
periodic table doesn't bring back much
nostalgia you feel quite detached from
it I think it's really quite nice it's I
suppose bullets and old friends I used
to look at it a lot but also it's quite
like seeing a young person who's now
grown up because this is the young
periodic table and nowadays it's grown
more I wouldn't like to say fatter but
it's growing more because it's got lots
more elements and I think that when I
was young I didn't imagine that there
would be many more elements in the
periodic table and to be quite honest
when we started these periodic videos I
wasn't expecting that many more elements
would be discovered and named and we've
already had three new elements named
since we started the videos and I think
there going to be some more names soon
so it's really an exciting time to be
studying chemistry and looking at the
periodic table I
not quite saw where it came from my
parents got it for me it was sponsored
by the International nickel company they
didn't have websites in those days but
they had some address that you could
send off for them I seem to remember
that the periodic table arrived in a big
cardboard tube was really exciting and I
think this was just inside rolled up as
a sort of extra freebie and you can see
here's the remains of the sticky tape
that was used to stick it onto the wall
of my bedroom I guess that when I took
it off some of the wallpaper also came
off - but that's disappeared now
I've got one more question what was the
table on page one to eight and it's a
bit boring I think well perhaps not it
has a whole series of elements from
potassium to gold and all sorts of
different reactions how they react with
water
potassium initiative note goes with a
good bang even Neal runs away from it
wears gold doesn't react at all you can
wash your hands wearing a wedding ring
and so on but imagine making the poor
pupils copy out things like that
chemistry is not about learning things
by heart it's about understanding things
though you do have to remember some
facts